and in South Carolina Alec murdo's
defense team is expected to rest its
case today in his double murder trial
the disgraced lawyer denies killing his
wife and son in June of 2021 and he gave
emotional testimony from the witness
stand last week but prosecutors say he
is lying Nikki Batiste has been
following his trial since it began as it
comes to a close Nikki good morning
Tony good morning as this trial enters
its sixth week another twist berdahl was
charged with a misdemeanor Friday after
court adjourned for what remains unclear
but it comes with closing arguments in
this dramatic trial on the horizon
during nearly six hours of testimony on
Friday Alec murdaugh denied murdering
his wife and son I can promise you I
would hurt myself
before I would hurt one of them but he
did concede a history of lying about
millions of dollars in financial fraud
his addiction to opioids and even his
whereabouts on the night of the murders
admitting he'd been at the crime scene
before they happened despite telling law
enforcement otherwise everything about
me not going to the kennel was a lie and
you're able to just do that that's so
easily and so convincingly and so
naturally don't you
that's not for me to judge CBS News
legal analyst Ricky cleeman says
murdaugh's Decades of experience as a
lawyer served him well on the witness
stand going far beyond yes or no answers
to prosecutors questions he was about as
experienced to witness as I have ever
seen that you hurt the ones you loved
the most didn't you I did say that
you're implying to this jury and to me
that that was
me talking about hurt and Maggie and
Paul
and that's not what that was the
prosecution says murdo's alleged motive
to kill was to distract from his
financial crimes the defenses portrayed
him as a family man who would never do
such a thing the defense just has to
poke holes in the case in order to raise
Reasonable Doubt and all they need is
one juror
Clayman told us that in criminal cases
the prosecution does not have to prove
motive but she says in this case the
prosecution's theory may be difficult
for the jurors to believe the defense
attorneys say they will call Four
Witnesses today before resting their
case Nate
Nikki thank you it is such a fascinating
case Nate however this turns out I
really want to hear what the jurors are
thinking what they believed it'll be
interesting to see what they believe and
who they believe in this particular case
the defense only needs one that's right
right about that